the two hundred and thirty-nine program
lovelies each of the world
take you through the product loud
district in northern lowers
which has a deep connections with the
war in vietnam
the nineteen fifty two jimmy vo
agreement setup terms
under with the coalition government
would rule out
with the extreme right headed by prince
of on a puma
and the left the product nao led by
print supernova
united states began bombing areas in
northern lalit
about a year-and-a-half ago on the
ground that the north vietnamese would
bringing supplies over the so-called
procurement rail
school hours and into itself vietnam
strategic bombing bart b_-fifty two
weeks in fly through december
raises the question of whether the war
in vietnam will to spread two levels
by japanese news-gathering team
visits and newark
near the north vietnamese border
eighty villages three thousand expand
your is in the center of the product lal
controlled
the village was abandoned when the
bombing began
now from time to time some of the people
return
stories open only from four to seven in
the morning to avoid air attack
people appeared to be calm
but this soldiers carrying guns
symbolized the agony of war in this area
about the private honshu love has a
population of only two and a half
million
quiet un were like people
they are buddhist in many temples that
scattered throughout the area
order priests have left the region under
bombing and only the young monks remain
the local people say that all of the
part of a lot of different have been bal
united states bombing concentrates on
the road
villages
a part of a lot of conflict general was
established informed sali two hundred
fifty kilometers north west of sam know
people left the towns and villages when
the bombing began about a
year-and-a-half ago
they went into the mountains and jungles
to begin on you like
they say they can easily avoid the
attacks
by a living in the mouth
they had started a whole new villages
like this one near spaniel
it since the men who have volunteered
for either army third or work in the
factories only women children and the
older people who are left behind
inability
the women are pounding rights and
weeping
they have a fairly comfortable life
better than during the french colonial
period
there is that they can who will be in
the product loud districts in the people
provide for most of their own daily
needs
military training at a recognized part
of their daily lives
you laotian malaysia like the vietnamese
is a part of the people's liberation
army
it is established in various districts
the people makes
beer is before leaving for training
they listened intently to the group
leader
who explains that brightest influences
gathering in the government and the
n_c_o_
neutral it likes without a poem a
whitbread foreign intervention
in trying to follow the nineteen fifty
two can devote agreement they have
refused united states intervention in
order to avoid being drawn into the
vietnamese warner
but the rights welcome intervention by
the united states
in view of the conflict the product
lower could bring about might change of
power in the n_c_r_
despite the plans political situation
life in the mountain villages continues
peacefully
is the wedding day for a couple in the
bill
young girls are a busy preparing for
their feet
there are plenty of food
one man prepares a pic
the bride and groom walk toward their
new on and the ceremony begins
wedding guests leave money and get some
of the table set up for the occasion
laotians playskool deming hands of the
bride and groom
they have another erecting cut them
trying their hand together
with black cotton strength
laotians believe that the more spring
day you'll lose the great it will be
that happen it's or the newlywed
outside they have been preparing to
bring ten dollars everyone feel
dancing follows the wedding ceremony
everyone got to the lamp on which
originated in thailand
but had become popular involved
they caved built into the limestone of
the mountain near town mila
are the center of most village activity
here are the people who are state from
the bombing
although the kids are cold and damp the
village people for nixon and make them
as profitable as they can
there are underground classroom
during a period of the french
colonialists
ninety-eight percent of the people were
ill-equipped
you know lulls there were only three
hundred teachers in nineteen forty five
now there are four hundred he carries in
that part of a loud depict alone
and the number of children attending
school
has increased by a threefold in the last
and here
there should be on a repair shop in
samuel
here are young mechanics
learn how to make repairs
in the part of a lot of district they
follow the chinese slogan of working out
through your own airport
the idea if you develop
self-reliant
people in the part of our districts also
make their own textiles
even their own mentors
about fifty men work at the shop
their repaired one hundred thirteen cars
from january through september it's bad
here
this is a rest
the men are smoking quite native bamboo
spent
there is also a blacksmith shop in the
state where thirty employees
work six-and-a-half hours a day
there are three practices in which the
men meltdown pieces of bombs
dropped in nearby areas
hi kids
nyas
and ever called to olympic
last year the product lyle built between
plant for a girl's seventeen to nineteen
working a lot of flight
power is bernie five foot pedal
the girls make military uniforms breaks
and start
the grill employees saying they are not
afraid of the enemy
they will willingly indoor any hardship
no matter how long the fight goes on
there will be no happen is for anyone
until united states to defeat
you're also printing shop
send the radio broadcasting station in
the state
there through the print shop with a lot
about that
the central party or i don't know the
amount patriotic front is public
about thirty people are employed in the
shop
which spreading too many adjoining it
gave
divided into metall press roman
conference room and so forth
also located in the cave this is the
only broadcasting station in a pot of
allowed etc
it broadcast eight thirty minute program
today mostly new
one-half our program consists of music
most of the news programs are in laotian
but the barn broadcast are made in frank
nearest amnio abhi lodging people's
liberation army
has established a military school called
me to comment on military school in on
ur all that you will of the war against
the french
goal was prompted fifteen years ago
during the resistance war
when the people's liberation army fought
against a d_n_c_ on government
in metabolic at in com along provinces
follows seven dollars and had control of
some areas
it was a day before graduation and the
student when their final pages untrained
they learn to do leave of the soldiers
of out in people's liberation army
to destroy the enemy
whom all eyes the people
to participate in production
graduation withheld in one of the larger
tape
commentary he bombed on
is that prine commander of the lotion
people dot meet
to the gradually
the battle will be long and difficult
instead
all graduates must at all time show any
were like spirit of self-sacrifice
to do everything they can to overcome
the enemy and expand the liberated areas
graduating class
cheery their leader
print storefront along with the head of
the laotian patriotic front or i'd love
is fifty seven years old
is a hot brother of friends about a poem
when its rebuttal bond returned to laos
in nineteen forty one
after several years education in prague
he worked on a road construction project
during that period he became aware of
the poor living conditions of the people
and excited in nineteen forty five to
work toward independence
when he laotian patriotic front which
won the nineteen fifty six
he was elected as champ
interview he stated the tensioning
confusion and lowered
idea of growth of a conspiracy by the
united states and to run a puma
and the right of government in the empty
on contract elite geneva agreement
of nineteen thirty six
or year and a half united sates bombings
have been getting a lot
moreover united faith users motion and
south vietnamese agent
to bring these southern and central part
of the house
under its control and tooling south
vietnam with violent
he doesn't consider that the problem
because the united it can be four to
pull out
each day to the president lankan
government has the mark of the people
collision government but is actually a
puppet of the united states
which you talked about it for months
who carry out aggressive plank
that is why the people are determined to
resist
steaming and at that
although a recognized leader of the
laotian patriotic front
supernovae onto the friendly man who
even take time out of his busy day
to take physical training and keep in
close touch
with the younger people
of the move
that had been a translation
of the japanese commentary
on a visit to the product lower
every